[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts de l'actualité de la semaine à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avait
clamé côté thibault dogues ont gentiment
genre l'yonne est notre invité cette
semaine et christian jacob
bonjourbonjour député de seine et marne
vous êtes président du groupe l'est
républicain l'assemblée nationale merci
d'être avec nous cette semaine et dans
l'actualité parlementaire il ya d'abord
ce marathon à l'assemblée nationale 14
heures de débats sur les thèmes du grand
débat national
les députés ont pu faire leurs
propositions mais le gouvernement lui
réservent les siennes
de quoi susciter les critiques sur
l'utilité de cet exercice
dans le même temps senna ce sont les
ministres responsables du grand débat
qui ont été auditionnées et parmi les
thèmes évoqués à l'assemblée il y avait
d'abord la fiscalité le gouvernement a
cherché à prévenir les déceptions il n'y
aura pas de big bang fiscal a expliqué
bruno le maire
le groupe les républicains défendent et
lui ses propositions en la matière jeudi
dans l'hémicycle elles ont été rejetées
par la majorité que veut faire le
gouvernement sur la réforme des
institutions sur ce point aussi son
discours est resté sibyllin l'exécutif
paraît hésiter en particulier sur la
prise en compte ou non tu votes blancs
enfin une audition importante au sénat
celle du nouveau préfet de police de
paris didier lallement a détaillé le
dispositif renforcé déployés après les
dysfonctionnements constatés lors des
violences du 16 mars à paris et on
commence avec le grand débat national
qui s'est donc invité au parlement cette
semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux après midi et deux soirées de
débats et malgré tout une impression de
rendez vous manqués l'assemblée
nationale a longuement débattu des
quatre thèmes du grand débat cette
semaine à l'idée était de permettre aux
députés de faire entendre leurs
propositions
problème le gouvernement n'avait pas
d'annoncé à faire
et faute d'enjeu l exercice a été boudé
par une partie des députés
le gouvernement a tenté de se justifier
ils étaient venus écouter leur des
annonces viendra ensuite a expliqué le
ministre de l'ecologie françois
d'origine l'écoutent je veux dire
monsieur jacob je vous réponds très
concrètement très calmement
vous le savez parfaitement bien mais
vous essayez évidemment de sans doute de
d'animer un peu le débat je vais le
prendre comme cela mais vous savez très
bien que nous respectons les différentes
étapes donc le gouvernement moi en tant
que ministre je ne vais pas aujourd'hui
faire des propositions alors que et il y
à une restitution qui doit voir le 8
avril et sans jacob on a entendu le
ministre vous répondre vous regrettiez
que le gouvernement ne soient pas venus
avec des propositions c'était un débat
pour rien c'est une grande mascarade
tout ça ne ressemble à l'assemblée
nationale comme le sénat ça n'est pas à
une salle des fêtes un gymnase
on est en fait la loi c'est à dire que
après depuis le temps que dure ce ce
débat en fait quand on parle de débat
d'ailleurs ses monologues successifs du
président de la république c'est plutôt
sale la réalité des choses
on est en droit d'attendre des
propositions et qu'il y ait sur la table
un texte c'est comme ça que l'assemblée
fonctionne c'est d'ailleurs le
gouvernement et initiatives mais un
texte et à partir de là et bien on
travaille dessus en commission avec des
amendements des propositions et puis
amendement par amendement on vote
article après article
et c'est comme ça que se construit la
loi donc ça c'est ce qui se fait dans
95% des cas il ya une autre possibilité
celle où l'opposition mais une
proposition de loi sur la table donc
nous l'avons fait et nous l'avons fait
jeudi
mais là aussi le gouvernement refuse la
discussion c'est à dire si ça vient de
l'opposition donc c'est refusé avant
même qu'il y ait débat d'hier vous avez
bien noté qu'il y avait pas de débat
c'est une succession de monologues
d'intervention puisque forme qui
empêchait la forme et se souvenant enfin
la forme et le fond mais c'est surtout
de ne pas avoir mis une proposition sur
la table en disant voilà après cinq mois
de crise voilà ce que l'on met sur la
table
et puis chaque groupe politique bat
essaie de corriger le texte par voie
d'amendement mais mais mais là c'est
succession de monologues pour rien c'est
qu'on a bloqué une semaine complète
puisque cette semaine a été rythmée sur
ce sujet et on remet ça la semaine
prochaine comme s'ils savaient pas été
suffisant les résultats on a vu c'est
vrai cette image dans l'hémicycle aux
trois quarts vide pendant deux jours
est-ce qu'au moment où il ya un climat
d' antiparlementarisme ce n'est pas
donné le bâton pour se faire battre
oui mais enfin l'assemblée est là pour
travailler là ça sert à quoi on n'est
pas obligé de tomber dans tous les
pièges du côté on n'est pas là pour vous
c'est un piège s'est passé c'est inutile
enfin c'est pas inutile pour le
gouvernement puisque l'objectif on le
connaît bien c'est de faire durer et
donc on fait du rieur d'y envoyer on
écouté tout le monde on a consulté tout
le monde mais si vraiment le
gouvernement était dans dans cet état
d'esprit à ce moment là lorsque nous
faisons une proposition de loi jeudi
mais comme nous l'avons
d'autres occasions dans les niches
parlementaires et bien le gouvernement
accepte de rentrer dans le débat il nous
contrer argument contre argument mais là
ça n'est même pas le cas ça vient de
vous donc hors de question d'en discuter
on fait une motion procédure et on vous
renvoie dans vos 18 même nom va on va
revenir sur votre proposition de loi un
petit peu plus tard dans l'émission mais
d'abord autre type d'exercice 1 au sénat
sur ce grand débat puisque les sénateurs
ont choisi d'auditionner les deux
ministres en charge du grand débat
emmanuelle wargon et sébastien lecornu
c'était jeudi matin 1h30 des changes et
je vous propose d'écouter un extrait de
cette audition c'est un échange entre le
sénateur philippe dominati et le
ministre sébastien lecornu à propos du
coût de ce grand débat je voudrais
connaître le coût réel
le coût réel de ce débat pour l'état et
pas le coût caché que l'on découvrira
peut-être plus tard nous avions estimé
le coût global entre 10 et 15 millions
d'euros
on va être globalement à 12 millions
d'euros les débats sur le coût du grand
débat me semble intéressant mais
justement ils sont à mettre en
perspective de ce que coûte la
démocratie et pour jean jacob un mot sur
ce qu'on vient d'entendre le coût de ce
grand débat 12 millions d'euros cela
vous choque
12 millions d'euros pour servir ses
dires le la notoriété en quelque sorte
du président de la république parce que
c'est une mise en scène du président de
la république ces débats
regardez ce serait amusant de faire une
compilation de chacun des débats des
reprises médiatique
c'est une mise en scène de sa personne
donc voilà bon la république a dépensé
12 millions pour que le président de la
république puisse se met se met en scène
le même président et les mêmes ministres
n'hésitent pas à considérer qu'il ya
trop d'élus trop payés et qu'ils ne font
pas bien leur travail là on y va et est
vraiment se drape dans la vertu redisant
mais comment tout ça coûte très cher
mais là le président de la république
non faut soigner sa mise en scène et et
on n'ajoute pas ça j'imagine que n'a pas
été comptabilisé 2 dans la mobilisation
des forces de sécurité c'est quand même
invraisemblable c'est à dire que à
chaque fois on compte par centaines les
policiers les gendarmes qui sont
mobilisés pour que le président de la
république puisse aller délivrer son
discours
c'est simple vous dites sur plusieurs
mines at il un coût caché 2 millions ce
n'est pas le bon chiffre
je sais pas je n'ai pas d'éléments pour
le contester dont je peux faire un
procès d'intention mais la réalité c'est
que je n'en sais rien je dis est ce
qu'il est ministre on fait le bilan il
ya un million et demi de citoyens qui
ont participé à ce débat c'est ce n'est
qu'à liège doléances 10000 réunion est
ce que ce n'est quand même pas un succès
ce grand débat oui c'est important je
crois du corps électoral la peine vous
êtes un échec je pense que si on avait
des élus ancré sur le territoire ce qui
est d'ailleurs un des problèmes pour
l'ailé parlementaire en marche qui n'ont
pas cet ancrage territorial et
d'ailleurs on a supprimé
c'est assez amusant le comportement à
l'égard des mères vont ça vous a pas
échappé aux notes dans un premier temps
les maires ont été accusés de tous les
maux d'organiser j'irai des débats sion
des bastions locaux de vivre sur leur
pré carré etc
et puis après d'un seul coup quand on a
vu qu effectivement que l'opinion
publique elle soutient les les maires
dont revirement les mères étaient
devenus des gens formidables de
proximité qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
soigner
entre temps on avait fait l'opération
balances ton mer mené par monsieur
darmanin bon tout ça n'est pas très
n'est pas très sérieux et il ya un
objectif gagner du temps et mettre en
scène le président de la république le
premier ministre doit s'exprimer
désormais devant l'assemblée mardi le
sénat mercredi sur les conclusions du
grand débat qu'en attendez vous ben rien
puisque le premier ministre s'est
lui-même je referai pas d'annonce donc
on va être encore dans un débat pour
rien puisque une fois de plus il va en
tirer les conclusions mais sans faire de
propositions puisque la mise en scène là
aussi c'est le président de la
république
on va encore sans doute ça va sans doute
encore coûté beaucoup d'argent pour
soigner sa mise en scène pour ce qu'il
puisse faire ses effets d'annoncé
puisque les ministres sont interdits
d'annoncés de propositions concrètes
c'était d'ailleurs c'est affligeant de
on va rentrer de les voir là dans
l'hémicycle tête baissée sur leur
smartphone à écouter attendre puisque
interdit de voir entrer dans le fond des
sujets justement avec d'abord celui sur
la fiscalité ce débat sur la fiscalité
les dépenses publiques il s'est déroulé
mardi soir à l'assemblée nationale
le gouvernement l'a encore à avancer
masqué si l'exécutif a bien pris le
pouls du ras-le-bol fiscale relayée par
de nombreux français
il exclut tout big bang en la matière
résumé des débats avec les gogos
grégoire l'heure n'est pas encore aux
propositions lors du débat sur la
fiscalité aucune annonce concrète n'a
été faite par le gouvernement mais à
l'évidence l'exécutif maintient le cap
bruno le maire l'a répété il est
favorable à une baisse des impôts mais
sous conditions seule la dépense
publique
bc doit nous permettre de financer cette
baisse d'impôts de son côté le ministre
de l'action et des comptes publics a
confirmé la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation pour l'ensemble des
contribuables
nous avons évidemment à accomplir la
promesse du président de la république
puis l'engagement du président de la
république à la fin de l'année 2010
celle de la suppression à 100 % de la
taxe d'habitation sans les résidences
secondaires
d'ici la fin du quinquennat du président
de la république c'est à dire d'ici de
l'année budgétaire 2020 deux autres
thématiques abordées la remise à plat
des niches fiscales
gérald darmanin a évoqué la possibilité
d'évaluer leur efficacité
donc si le parlement ici le plf c'est un
travail sur lequel bercy est tout à fait
prêt à couvrir tous les livres
d'évaluation des niches
nous sommes tout à fait disposés à ce
que la justice fiscale soit au rendez
vous rétablir lisf plus de justice
fiscale tout au long de la séance elle
les différents groupes d'opposition
n'ont pas manqué de faire des
propositions
mardi prochain le premier ministre sera
très attendu sur ces questions lors de
son discours à l'assemblée nationale
alors christian jacob le midi pas de big
bang fiscal les français risquent d'être
déçus est-ce qui est ce qui va moi je
relève de deux phrases qui sont assez
intéressantes
d'une part de dire le gouvernement
maintient le cap
c'est quand même assez surprenant de
dire on écoute on est à l'écouté des
français on est même allé coûte de l'eau
de l'opposition etc
mais de toute façon on maintient le cap
donc fermer le ban il n'y aura aucun
changement là et croustillant
deuxième élément assez croustillant si
la déclaration de monsieur darmanin qui
nous annonce la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation pour le prochain
quinquennat
moi je vous garantis que je peux prendre
beaucoup d'engagement effectivement pour
le prochain quinquennat ou celui encore
après demain on rase gratis mais demain
pas aujourd'hui le gouvernement sent
quand même repris le constat du raz le
bol fiscale et prévoit sans doute
d'abaisser la pression fiscale pour une
partie des français notamment les
classes moyennes inférieures c'est une
bonne nouvelle sur ce point vous y
croyez bah écoutez la moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que la démonstration n'est
elle n'a pas été fait
à ce stade on vient de battre tous les
records sur des prélèvements
obligatoires on a passé pour la première
fois de notre histoire la barre des 45 %
de prélèvements obligatoires
ce gouvernement si vous prenez
aujourd'hui les critères économiques qui
sont intéressants celui de montant de la
dette publique la dépense publique le
montant de la dette le déficit et la
balance commerciale
ces quatre points sont assez riches
d'enseignement parce que la dépense
publique
on voit effectivement si l'état continue
à dépend à dépenser plus que ce qu'il ne
gagne si vous prenez l'endettement on
sait que l'endettement d'aujourd'hui ce
sont les impôts de demain
le taux des prélèvements obligatoires et
la balance les résultats de la balance
commerciale qui elles sont un élément
important de compétitivité de nos
entreprises comment on va chercher des
points de croissance extérieure sur ces
quatre critères macron c'est hollande en
pire
parce que à chaque fois depuis deux ans
il a aggravé la situation
on a augmenté la dette de manière très
importante
depuis deux ans on a augmenté les
dépenses publiques les prélèvements
obligatoires ont augmenté et la balance
commerciale s'est totalement dégradée
donc deux ans et c'est important au bout
de deux ans on peut commencer à regarde
surtout qu d'ailleurs si on voulait très
objectif ça fait pas deux ans ça fait
sept ans en réalité que le président de
la république est impliqué dans la
politique économique puisqu'il a été
d'abord le conseiller de françois de
françois hollande il a été ensuite son
ministre de l'économie des finances et
les maintenant président de la
république
et depuis qu'il est là les deux ans
vraiment il a toutes les manettes
la situation se dégrade pas
par rapport à ce qu'il était saoul ou
hollande donc macron sur le plan
économique c'est hollande en pire malgré
tout s'il y avait une baisse de la
pression fiscale par exemple une sur un
allègement des deux premières tranches
de l'impôt sur le revenu comme le
propose le groupe la république en
marche vous le soutiendrez y est c'est
la baisse du taux de l'impôt sur le
revenu ça c'est la proposition que nous
nous nous avons fait moi sur le reste
j'attends de voir mais on a eu tellement
d'entourloupe surtout voyez on est
aujourd'hui on est au mois deux mois
d'avril avec un budget totalement
insincère d'ailleurs c'était souligné
pas par moi mais par la cour des comptes
qui souci souligne la sincérité c'est à
dire qu'on fait des annonces budgétaires
qui ne sont pas financés par exemple la
taxe d'habitation
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas comment les
financer donc de fait ça se traduit par
des augmentations de dette donc de
l'impôt demain et est ce qui m'a amené
d'ailleurs à le dire un moment dans le
débat avec le le ministre du du budget
nous avons une dette qui augmente donc
un ministre qui a menti en permanence en
nous expliquant mais la charge de la
dette le sujet c'est pas celui là
la charge de la dette à l'ailier
d'ailleurs aux taux d'intérêt la réalité
c'est que la dette augmente depuis que
monsieur macro et là par rapport à ce
qu'était la situation soit hollande
alors on va parler de votre proposition
de loi christian jacob puisqu'on parle
de fiscalité votre groupe défendent est
une proposition de loi pour rendre aux
français
plusieurs milliards de pouvoir d'achat
le texte proposait notamment de revenir
sur la hausse de la csg pour les
retraités et la réindexation de leur
retraite des revendications portées par
de nombreux gilet jaune mais sans se
rendre surprise il a été repoussé par le
gouvernement et la majorité le grégoire
suppression de la hausse de la csg ré
indexation des pensions de retraite
la proposition de loi portée par les
républicains avait comme objectif de
rétablir le pouvoir d'achat des français
le manque de dimension humaine dans vos
réformes a surtout réveiller chez nos
concitoyens un sentiment d'injustice
jamais vraiment dormir justice sociale
territoriale injustice entre les
générations le gouvernement pointe
l'incohérence du financement de toutes
ces mesures
votre proposition de loi estimé
aujourd'hui à 10 milliards d'euros selon
vous quasiment 10 est en réalité cette
proposition de loi s'apparente davantage
à une critique qu'à une véritable
proposition
cette critique la majorité ne l'entend
pas elle accuse un texte irresponsable
et démagogique
ce texte je les rebaptiser pjl d'orgue
comme demain on rase gratis
mais notre majorité n'a pas attendu
votre proposition de loi pour renforcer
le pouvoir de choc à gauche la
proposition de loi n'a également pas
convaincu ce qui nous ennuie dans votre
ppl c'est la manière dont vous financer
ces mesures c'est à dire par des coupes
massives entre 10 et 20 milliards
d'euros dans les dépenses publiques et
donc dans les services publics une
mention de renvoi en commission a été
voté à 90 voix pour contre 54 aucun
article n'a donc été examinées christian
jacob l'appel a donc été rejetée vous ne
le disais tout à l'heure on a
l'impression que l'opposition n'ait pas
écouté par ce gouvernement
elle n'a pas en réalité elle n'a pas été
rejetée il n'y a pas eu de débat c'est
ça qui est qui et qui est assez
invraisemblable et examens
le groupe parlementaire qui est l'autre
celui des républicains que les
spectateurs comprennent 15 c'est le
premier groupe d'opposition nous avons
100 104 député serre que plus que tous
les autres groupes d'opposition et nous
avons dans le règlement de notre
assemblée d'ailleurs dans la
constitution la possibilité trois fois
par an de présenter ce qu'on appelle une
journée de niche parlementaire donc on
présente des projets de loi alors
qu'habituellement les propositions noix
sont présentés par la majorité ou projet
de loi ce qui est d'ailleurs le la quasi
unanimité ou très généralement projet de
loi présenté par le par le gouvernement
donc il y a trois jours où on peux nous
présenter et là par une motion de
procédure
la majorité refuse qu'il y ait le débat
c'est à dire que nous nous présentons un
projet une proposition de loin avec
différentes mesures sur lequel on va
peut-être revenir et dire bon bah on
peut en débattre
article par article argument contre
argument non ils mettent une motion
procédure on en débat pour trois jours
par an tout le reste de l'année c'est la
majorité qui est qui qui a la maîtrise
de l'ordre du jour est là pour cette
journée au moins qu'on en débatte
article la partie mais même ça c'est
refuser que vous avez vous sur le dga de
la tournure des relations entre
l'exécutif et le parlement aujourd'hui
hawaïenne vraie dérive institutionnelle
jamais bon je vais pas beaucoup de
sympathie pour monsieur gossio lent mais
mais on est dans une situation qu'on n'a
jamais connu c'est à dire d'un mépris
total des élus d'une manière générale et
des parlementaires en particulier avec
un parlement qui en permanence méprisé
humilié on l'a vu sur la commission
enquête sur cette affaire
triste affaire benalla macron la manière
dont s'était bloqué le débat était
interdit à l'assemblée heureusement que
le sénat a fait cent ans a fait son
travail l'a à nouveau
j'avais demandé une commission denquête
sur ce qui s'est passé le 16 mars avec
des violence inouïe avec le limogeage
d'un préfet de police c'est pas quelque
chose d'anodin
le limogeage de hauts fonctionnaires de
police ça n'est pas anodin et j'ai
proposé même au président de l'assemblée
nationale en disant coûté la commission
denquête moi je ne demande pas la
préside et ne demande pas à ce que ce
soit les républicains mais faisons là
avec l'ensemble des groupes
et que le président de l'assemblée
nationale lui même la président ça ne
posait aucun problème mais simplement je
considère qu'il ya un rôle qui est celui
de l'assemblée qui a le pouvoir de
contrôler et de pouvoir exercer son
pouvoir de contrôle pour vérifier
comment les choses se sont se sont
passées les hordes ont ils été donnée
pas donné appliquée par qui comment
pourquoi cette transparence à les
refuser et la sueur situation si grave
que celle nous vivons depuis cinq mois
nous mettons sur la table des
propositions avec des mesures très
claires en matière de pouvoir d'achat
eh bien ça on nous refuse même le droit
d'en parler c'est interdit de circuler
de toute façon ça vient des républicains
on prend même pas le temps d'en parler
au maine motions de procédure et on
dégage tous
un mot sur le fond vous financer ces 10
à 17 milliards de pouvoir d'achat a
rendu aux français par des que
coûteraient ces baisses d'impôts via une
baisse des dépenses publiques mais c'est
autant d'argent qui n'iraient pas au dos
désendettement pour le coup vous nous en
parliez tout à l'heure
est ce qu'il n'ya pas là un problème il
ya eu deux parties c'est à dire qu'il ya
une partie effectivement majeur dans ce
cadre là après bon là on en est pas un
programme de gouvernement sur le
programme de gouvernement viendra le
temps où effectivement il ya une part
soit désendettement ce que nous faisons
c'est que nous finançons d'abord ces
mesures les mesures qu'on annonce c'est
se financent par une baisse de la
dépense publique donc ça passe par
d'abord une réforme de la réforme des
retraites ça passe aussi par une réforme
de la fonction publique
on considère qu'il faut diminuer le
nombre de postes c'est à dire en
compensant avec une augmentation du
temps de travail et une augmentation du
paiement c'est-à-dire des fonctionnaires
mieux payés
travaillant davantage qui nous permet de
gagner des postes et de faire des
économies
et puis d'autres mesures c'est la remise
en cause de l'aide médicale d'état et un
certain nombre d'autres points qui nous
permettent de financer cela mais lorsque
viendra le temps de présenter un
programme de gouvernement il y
effectivement vous avez raison une
partie des dépenses publiques qui seront
affectés à la au désendettement
allez vous parler des violences du 16
mars un creux dit didier lallement le
nouveau préfet de police de paris et est
auditionné au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
auditionné donc le nouveau préfet de
police de paris sur les violences qui
ont lieu à paris le 16 mars il n'était
pas en fonction
ce jour là puisqu'il a succédé à michel
delpech limogé suite à ces événements
mais didier lallement a évoqué le dépit
des forces de l'ordre à l'issue de cette
journée et dit avoir tiré les leçons en
matière de maintien de l'ordre résumé de
cette audition samia de chair le 16 mars
dernier certaines unités assiste
immobile aux violences sur les champs
elysées elles n'ont tout simplement pas
reçu l'ordre d'agir
le gouvernement promet alors une plus
grande sévérité et nomme un nouveau
préfet de police
didier lallement auditionné mercredi par
les sénateurs il a présenté la nouvelle
feuille de route
désormais chaque unité se verra
attribuer une mission sur un périmètre
précis pour plus d'autonomie sur le
terrain vous avez la mission et vous
l'avez dans ce périmètre géographique
c'est à dire qu'on n'attende pas l'ordre
de la salle pour agir
puisqu'on sait que la mission doit
s'effectuer dans telle zone géographique
plus autonome les forces de l'ordre
seront aussi plus mobile elles seront
progressivement équipés de véhicules
légers type de roue nous avons en face
de nous des gens extrêmement mobile
extrêmement mobiles très rapide qui
change de rue or nous notre système il
est basé sur des forces qui embarquent
dans des cars l'écart roulent les gens
les forces des barques
vous voyez bien que quoi qu'on fasse
dans un système comme ça la
manifestation mobile elle fera déjà
trois rues plus tard un dispositif qui
inquiète certains sénateurs
car il existe déjà des policiers à moto
les brigades de répression contre les
actions violentes très contesté ces
brigades ressemblent comme des soeurs
jumelles aux voltigeurs qui ont été
mises en cause dans la mort de malik
oussékine etc ont été dissous en 1986
une petite différence technique
les voltigeurs étaient sur des engins
légers nous on transporte nos gars c'est
des équipages qui font de 100 kg on les
transporte des engins de 9 centimètres
cubes je suis monté sur les motos
franchement si vous arrivez à tenir une
matraque sur un enjeu comme ça avec les
25 et on a franchement chapeau
autre inquiétude des sénateurs
l'utilisation des lanceurs de balles de
défense responsable de graves blessures
didier lallement a confirmé le maintien
de leur utilisation lors des prochaines
manifestations
christian jacob entre la nomination d'un
nouveau préfet de police et une nouvelle
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre est ce
que vous pensez que désormais il n'y
aura plus de violence dans les nouvelles
manifestations
alors elle a le le sujet on essaye de
nous expliquer qu'en changeant préfet de
police tout va bien aller rendez le
sujet c'est pas celui du préfet de
police
celui de la compétence du ministre de
l'intérieur et du premier ministre à
réagir face à ces actes de violence
parce que ce même préfet de police quand
il était en postant en aquitaine sauf
erreur de ma part il ya eu aussi des
violences et des dérapages scandaleux à
bordeaux et à toulouse donc le sujet ça
n'est pas le préfet de police
mais c'est celui qui lui donnent les
ordres et donc c'était l'incapacité de
réaction d'un ministre de l'intérieur le
sujet c'est christophe castel très
clairement un mot pour finir sur la
censure du conseil constitutionnel
concernant est la loi anti-casseurs
censure partielle mais censure de
l'article phare celui permettant à des
préfets de procéder à des interdictions
administratives de manifester est ce que
vous regrettez cette décision du conseil
constitutionnel
oui mais elle est d'abord le résultat de
l'hypocrisie du président de la
république qui présente un texte au
parlement qui le fait voter par sa
majorité et qui immédiatement le défaire
lui-même au conseil constitutionnel on
se doute en prêt vraisemblablement de la
réaction du conseil constitutionnel donc
c'est d'abord son hypocrisie
il a cherché à faire invalider cette
enquête a parfaitement battre est
clairement temps d c'est vraiment se
moquer du monde en disant je vous
présente une loi je demande à majorque à
ma majorité de voter cette loi
je demande au ministre du gouvernement
de se mobiliser dessus mais je la
défaire immédiatement pour être sûr que
l'article soit soient invalidés donc
maintenant si le président de la
république n'était pas aussi hypocrite
que je le dis et bien j'imagine qu'il va
faire une deuxième délibération et qu'on
peut très bien et réécrire ce texte pour
qu'il puisse être validée par le conseil
constitutionnel et que ce soit fait dans
les plus brefs délais visionner des
relations écoutez c'est le minimum à
faire ou alors c'est vraiment un
comportement hypocrite
merci beaucoup
merci tube on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle semaine
d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]